all right hyper said 140 words
and we are live apparently at high
refresh rate
high refresh rate welcome to the last
word with laura cagnino anybody
on that friday evening campfire nice
little special guest
action but first e how are you doing
what is going on with you you should be
smiling because of some announcements
i got to see gameplay for canon bridge
of spirits which is really cool i'm
looking forward to that game it looks so
so cool it might be like
it may be one of those like six hour
eight hour experiences if it's like an
ore in the blind forest but like
the animators who turn it into it looks
so cool and then
before that totally blown away elden
ring
official like two hour and 43 second
trailer i've watched it like four times
already
i cannot wait i'm completely pumped but
where are we talking about any and all
that stuff we got a man joining us if
you guys are in here watching it live
checking it out on video
you guys can see his face so let's get
this thing started and bring him in how
we always do
welcome to the last word episode number
153
it's christmas in june as it is that e3
time of year summer games fest kicked
off it with its huge announcement last
night
the next week should bring lots of news
and crazy about
crazy and fantastic upcoming games but
we go through the hyper roller coaster
this
like this year after year after year and
yet for the past seven years we have
been logging in nearly every tuesday to
check in on our guardians
and who better to take a look back at
things in destiny than our guest tonight
a man who grew up in the world of
playstation and knows a thing or two
about epic moments after some
time in the soul series he took his
passion for games and skills in writing
and made something unique in the destiny
community
if you go to buy for milan to learn
about the lore and story of destiny
then you should equally look to our
guest as your retrospective master
in all things in-game moments in the
franchise over the past couple of years
this man has made some of the best
videos
that take a deep dive into all the
activities moments and secrets this
franchise has given us
over the over the years he is a wizard
of time travel
as anyone who watches one of his videos
feels like they are right back in the
middle of each epic moment
so many many of us have experienced from
year one and a little activity called
prison of elders
to the infamous 24 hours of last wish
his videos will take you through the
journey of what it has been like to play
this crazy game over the course of the
past seven years
so without further ado and without a
twitter as well
sitting or standing at his mojo desk the
one the only
evan f1997 how are you doing tonight sir
i'm good how are you guys wow i was not
expecting that
crazy ass intro that was so cool that is
what we do man we got to bring into the
campfire in style
i was very happy that was a that was a
well written verse i appreciate that
from an actual collegiate writer it
needs some work but i'll take it
how are you doing man i'm good how are
you guys
i'm i'm i'm chilling today yeah good
luck
i don't know if you can hear my dogs
they're apparently excited to have you
on the podcast too
don't worry mark the car's bombing
they're excited too
no i was like i mean i'm gonna kind of
jump in basically at first and
say i know i exploded yesterday when
elden ring finally got announced
and i know you've played the souls
series so i want to get your kind of
history on the soul series a little bit
i know this is a destiny podcast
but i can't not talk about it so kind of
how much you played in souls
and then also just your quick take on
elden ring as well cause i'm pumped
i have played a lot of dark souls and
bloodborne and sakiro i think those
games are
probably if i'm not playing destiny
you'll catch me playing that like just
off stream just by myself
just absolutely like goblining just
sitting here at my desk just playing
like they're just
so addicting and endlessly replayable
and i mean i was just
blown away by the trailer yesterday i
think like it literally made my day i
was just in a good mood for the rest of
the day
nice nice yeah that thing looked amazing
man
like i said earlier we were talking i
mean i'm not a souls guy but you know
obviously the hype behind it
you know i thought artistically the
trailer really set a nice
mood it was just it looked phenomenal i
was really
impressed you know i'm saying i'm just
like man i know the souls community
has to be going crazy so e i'll bring it
back to you man like
when you just in like this tears of joy
did the tears well would you like i
wasn't i was like the tears
it wasn't specifically tears but we were
going through the full like 90 minute or
so presentation
i was working on stuff back and forth
catching the live things peeking back
seeing
and then like i'm hearing but i wasn't
quite looking at the screen because i
stepped away and they're like i got one
more i'm like
literally come running back in the room
sit down and i can see like the names
pop up and i was just like yes
yes like my stream's probably like
pulling their headphones away so that so
i don't like blow out their ears
thank you limiters so i don't do that um
no it was
it was really cool to know that it's
like the biggest game they've ever made
it's an open world setting and there's a
horse that you could just
jump onto at any point you have a you
have a you have a epona you have epona
and honestly what is it miyazaki i think
that's his name if i get the name right
yeah
um yeah has some zelda influence and
some things that he's enjoyed
so it's like seeing something like
basically a horse like a mount that you
can jump on for one kind of knows
how big the world's gonna be because you
need a horse to run around on it
and then on top of that you've got the
fact that like we're seeing like magical
swords come out and crazy looking boss i
mean it's a souls game for sure it has
all the feel
has looked like the sakura like
lightning come down with the dragon shot
that you had
all the bosses look crazy over the top
but it's
it's a full fantastical not quite the
lovecraftian that they've been doing for
a little while not bloodborne
it's its own thing with the george r
martin world building people may give
like game of thrones season eight
somehow
but like the world they built in like
one through six and seven is fantastic
so if it's anything of that level and
lore
man people are gonna be breaking that
thing down forever so i'm
i'm out of my mind and we got a date
like i thought it was just going to be
trailer cool it exists you know what he
and then it's like
january i was like yes and honestly
because i expect
destiny to probably be february i'm like
perfect i'll have time so oh yeah good
gives it a good space yeah it's like
for me because i think my first souls
game was
bloodborne back on back in peace
that was my first like i like jumped
into it was just like all right i heard
about this game
you know a friend recommended it to me i
hopped on there
like just completely played it for the
first time without any
any insight any help at all i got rolled
like my first day i think i spent 14
hours didn't get past the first section
like i was just so
bad it was so new to me i was like man
this is really not pulling any punches
but then
you know once you learn it and you kind
of understand that it's really just
dodge and hit
as weird as that sounds really just
dodge and hit it's like
this game you know like all right it's
pretty easy and then you just get better
and better and then
every single play through you get faster
you get you know you try new things
and then i jumped into dark souls one
right after
and was like wow like every single one
of these games
two two's a little different yeah i
heard two just rough
two is fun it takes a little bit of time
to get into but two is fun
yeah like especially you know you get
you get the iframes working for you then
two becomes a lot better but
three is like the one that i think a lot
of people really
modern day three probably holds up the
best out of any of the games yep
although i would say if bloodborne was
on pc that would probably be the one
that is 60
60 fps on pc give the modding community
something to do
the bloodborne would be perfect but i
mean now we get i mean secure was great
it was a little more linear
it was great but it was it was linear
which like you know for me
doesn't offer the same replayability
that the other games did but now
elden ring looks to be open world and a
combination of all of those
and i i just i i can't wait like it's
literally just gonna be everything that
i've been wanting out of one of these
games
and and more yeah um
yeah i was beyond pumped is there
anything else you guys have seen in the
last day or so i know we're so early
microsoft's big
big thing is obviously going to be
sunday i know cogniza is going to be
glued and talking for 12 hours about
that one um
yeah it's like i don't know how long you
got a voice but that you're going to
figure out where it is
um but what are you guys what else are
you guys looking forward to this week
before we jump into destiny because this
is
christmas in july i mean this is
literally the joke of e3 if you're if
you're a gamer at all
this time of year is hype it always is
and we're kind of back into the point
where now we have three
ig and summer of gaming summer games
fest and truly an e3 is back even in
more of a digital form this year
what are you guys looking forward to
let's get let's get him
what's your hype about everybody um i
watched a trailer yesterday for this
game called planet of lana
which is like a hand yeah
that game looked really cool uh
unfortunately hollow knight silk song is
not gonna get any news this year
like they just have nothing and that's
pain because
hollow knight is probably my other
favorite game outside of destiny that i
just love playing like
nice all right hollow knight silk song
whenever that drops
i'll be imma be on that instantly um
there's another one that i think like a
lot of people are really excited for it
it has like a lot of zelda inspiration i
don't remember what it's called though
but it's like um i think i know what
you're talking about i missed it yeah i
don't remember what it's called it's
like
like um it's like a female protagonist i
forgot i forgot what it's called but
that game looks dope
yeah man what about you cog there's a
ton man i mean
i got a lot of battlefield kind of
impressed me dude i was
i was yo i think it's that's kind of one
of those weird things about
not having seen one every single year in
occurring time like it's been a little
while it's had a chance to like
fall out and almost feel fresh and you
know you've had your shooters you've had
your battle royales this is just
big giant multi 128 players is insane
dude that is
that's a lot going on now granted there
could be giant maps you may never see
half the people but the fact that
there's anything that scale and it's
next gen only so you know it requires
the power it's like
that's sorry to steal your thunder there
but yeah okay i don't know you you're
literally on fire bro cause that's
literally how i felt you said it
perfectly like
you know the thing about battlefield is
it
you miss it because it's not the
annualized thing
and i remember i was a big card fanboy
like before battlefield i was just
god got it and my friend's like yo
battlefield's better and i'm like
and then i tried it and i'm like oh this
is
full-scale war oh oh this is vehicles
this
is you know and i remember playing three
and then playing four
and really getting hooked and my only
issue with the last
two was that i'm gonna be honest i'm
kinda i'm over the whole four scorers
and seven years ago
oh the historic stuff well i think
everybody is and that's the nice thing
yeah yeah i'm just i want modern so
bad so when i heard the rumor that it
was modern i'm like oh okay then the 128
and then i like the goofy stuff i like
them jumping out the
the play with the rocket launcher the
the other thing was um
what what four used to do was this thing
it was a scripted event but it was so
cool to me it was called evolution oh
yeah
and like that the building was destroyed
like big giant skyscraper would fall
down
cut the map in half and stuff yeah so
look 128 players i know there's a bit of
controversy because there's no campaign
i i get it
you know but i still have to admit it it
looked really cool to um
evan's point yeah that uh what is that
plan of lana game that game
really sick i will say um what is like
the
isometric mmo diablo amazon game you
know what i'm talking about that i was
like why does
first off an amazon game and i'm not
sure i trust any of those until they're
literally playable or for more than a
minute
but two it's like an isometric mmo and i
was so confused i was like it seems kind
of cool but also kind of
weird that one kind of threw me off it
was like it was like the amazon one
right
the amazon mmo yeah or luca or something
like that
no it's called like new world new
world's like a world of warcraft thing
there's like they have a set but i
didn't even know they had a second game
so they actually have another one from
amazon so yeah i was very surprised that
that's there so
there were some interesting ones i mean
xbox obviously is going to
try and steal the entire week with
everything they can possibly drop so i'm
very curious
how much you see about halo crazy yeah
like i think
i think we actually see something about
like bethesda stuff from xbox like i
think we see a lot of bethesda stuff
because they just bought them earlier
this year
elder scrolls six i don't know if we get
an announcement i think we if anything
we get like another little like weird
teaser
but then there's that space ip that they
were gonna make because it was just
maybe
starfield yeah i feel like we get more
info on that
like maybe like not a lot but just
something
and then i there's there's supposed to
be next week is supposed to be loaded
we're supposed to find out way more
about elden ring on tuesday we're
supposed to find out like a lot on
tuesday
like tuesday's supposed to be like the
big day for everything
i work till about noon and then i'm
gonna just be glued so
oh yeah game of christmas same thing i'm
hyped
you know starfield let's see what's
going on with that the potential
showcase we see what they want that
you know next week is even more and
breath of the wild too
like yeah i've been so busy i'll be
again apologies for me running a little
late today but that's right you know
just being on podcasts and everyone
wants to talk everyone's excited it's
that time of year game of christmas man
so yeah i'm hyped brother i'm hype man
yeah
well outside of the world of non-destiny
stuff which i'm sure some of you guys
were like can we get to the destiny
stuff now please
um but no like uh destiny is
kind of honestly hitting its stride
perfectly right now between the
storytelling that they're doing
uh the world that they're kind of
setting up and things like that and
before we go too far i kind of wanted to
ask you evan about some of what you've
been through
over the past couple of years in just
this like
explosion on your videos and how you've
been doing these
i can't think any better way to say it
just like the amazing retrospectives
that you do about
any topic activity event rate rate
whatever it is like
how did you what made you decide to do
that and then in the depth that it did
with like
what was the explosion that caused you
like this is like my thing i found my
niche like what
what what kicked that off and where to
begin
so like it all kind of began when i was
there was a summer where i decided like
you know i i had this like internship
kind of like like paid internship
opportunity working for this cool
company like this corporation doing the
you know boring like corporate video
work pretty much but
it would have been like really good on
like a resume and i decided i was like
you know
i kind of don't like doing this but i
also really like making content i always
like
like i always enjoyed making videos um
so i like started doing some guide stuff
and then i found that guides weren't
really making me happy like i wasn't
really enjoying
talking about like how to get this title
how to do this thing like
it's not for everybody and it wasn't for
me and then one day
i just remember this like very very
clearly like one day
there was i made a guide on solo
flawless pit of heresy
and that video like did really well like
the first day i think it had like a
hundred thousand views and i was like
holy
hell like people really like this no
okay cool
let me let me try something new because
there was this
whole thing about bagel 4k and super
duper
going for 999 power like that season
and i got like a lot of attention i was
like you know
i i like i like thought to myself i was
like nobody is really
talking about like the community side
and that's the side that i'm always like
interested in is like the people that
are doing cool things
in these games like taking things the
devs don't really intend
for them to do and just pushing the
boundaries forward because like for me
that just shows that people love the
game and like they're so committed
and i think that's the part that like on
youtube especially people are like dude
i want to hear about that and like i
always want to hear about that stuff
and i kind of thought to myself i was
like you know every time i do a raid
every single time i do a raid somebody
is like on lfg somebody's just like
hey you remember when this thing was
busted for this
and then somebody else is like yeah i do
and then somebody else is like
no i don't i didn't play during that
time then i was like
okay well nobody's really talking about
that stuff and that's the stuff that
everybody wants to talk about that's
stuff that i like talking about
so let me just make a video about this
the whole 999 power situation because i
figured like
i was gonna try to be like the community
destiny news guy
yes and then that video exploded i think
in like two days it hit like a million
views and i was like holy [ __ ] like this
is crazy
and then and then like right after i was
like
okay but now i'm gonna do guides and
some of this stuff so i like did a
couple
guides like like how to get this
challenge done in garden of salvation
and then i did like
where does garden of salvation rank
among the best raids and i had a really
now looking back at it i now know to
like
not rank raids after a week or two but
like give them
some time to settle yeah yeah
because like if you're a moment if you
don't you put garden of salvation in a
very high regard when i don't think
garden is my favorite raid by any means
i think it's like lower
very low on my list of rates but um
and then i was just like i i kind of
thought about it and i
i thought to myself i was like man
there's so many cool stories of like
weapons
and just like uh raids like community
stories
that have happened in this game and
there's nobody that has made
anything about it and i just figured
you know i'm gonna talk about this
community story with um
the last wish raid race i'm going to
talk about niobe labs i'm going to talk
about this stuff and like
because because i wanted to do just
community focused things at first like
that was my goal was like i want to do
community stuff like just the stuff
that just involves this hardcore
community
that did really well but then i kind of
thought to myself i was like
there's you know there's just there's uh
there's a lot but there's also not a lot
and i feel like people also
kind of want to know about other things
and they kind of maybe watch this
in a more nostalgic way too like they
almost have like a nostalgia about it i
was like
i don't necessarily like my goal was
never to be
a straight-up nostalgia channel like
that wasn't my goal was to be like the
history guy
my goal was to talk about just the
community stories and then go to other
games talk about their community stories
but then people really liked it and then
i really liked it too so i was like all
right let me try to make a video about
this exotic weapon the gal horn and then
let me make a video about this thing and
then everybody is like
oh man i'm like i've been waiting on
this video i've been waiting for you to
cover this topic so people are like
hyped anticipating certain videos to
come out
of people what they want yeah amc
presents the
history of destiny with their our host
tonight mr evan
f yeah it was just like
it's crazy like and there's still so
much to talk about but
yeah i mean it's just it's crazy how far
it's come i wanted to shout you out on
that because um
i think like just hearing you explain it
and and
how you kind of got into that pocket
because when i came across your content
that's literally what i felt i was like
this is like the
destiny history channel in the sense of
where
where it where you were in that moment
like
exactly what was happening what was
going on how did the community feel how
was it received and you do it in such a
good way
it's just so well done especially the
niobe labs i remember that one
particularly
that was really good you know just
seeing how people were putting it
together and then the weapons and they
this one had to have this weapon and
each stage of the puzzle
until it got there you know and just to
even the way you capture
the excitement from people at the time
and stuff like that
it's really well produced really well
done obviously i'm
i'm a vault guys i was very biased very
happy to see
your uh your coverage on the vault of
glass of water
important to desert because there's some
people who just think it's this
nostalgic raid and that's all it was
but it had truly never been done and it
was
well done and to see how you chronicle
that it was just
cool so i love how you have that pocket
and you kind of embraced it because you
realize hey
people they do want this they do enjoy
this content from you
and for you to continue to do that stuff
and also
look out for more stuff that they ask
you about it's pretty cool so i got
three
thank you no sorry go ahead
i was just gonna say like thank you like
that's it yeah it's just
it's been it's been a journey that's all
i could say so i wanted to ask like
three items i wanted to go
hardest of your videos to make favorite
video to make
and the one that you're afraid to make
okay
uh hardest video i've ever made
is one that is actually not out on
youtube and i don't want to like
shameless plug
but it is out on patreon hey there you
go um
that is the 15th wish video the unsolved
mystery of destiny 2's 15th wish
when that hits youtube it will explode
that video
is that video took two and a half
months of just like pre-production
production
effects like all this research because
it was just like archived reddit threads
archived like bungee forum threads like
archived
everything and then also going in game
getting shots getting cinematics
getting people um there's a ton of
creators
who help with the voice over like let me
i can go through and just like
just give me one second i'll i'll i'll
go through and i'll just like list off
some of the creator names there's a i
decided to kind of
join an idea from daily dose of uh of
internet
and just say like you know let me get
some other creators on the platform on
the destiny side of things
and see if they're down to uh to help me
with the the 15th wish video like see if
they're down
to like talk about this or like just
down to
uh like do a voiceover for stuff like
basically
it's reddit threads that they hopped in
and they like read what the reddit
people wrote down
i don't want to imagine this like it's
milon bife mp
marcos sweatsicle fallout and like just
there's just the list goes on like
there's just a lot of people that's
awesome
uh what was the second question again
sorry so um
favorite video you've made so far
favorite video
um it kind of changes a lot uh
i would probably have to say for a while
it was the uh
it was the last wish video because like
i had a lot of like
my own personal bias to why i liked that
video like it was just like
something that i was very excited to
talk about um
other than that i would probably say i i
like like even though i love
the the history videos it's also stuff
that i've personally experienced and i'm
sharing with other people
the stuff that i really enjoy like the
most to make is more like feedback
pieces like more critical
kind of like talking about stuff so like
i really enjoyed destiny 2 is too easy
like that video was so much fun to make
for me because it was literally just
like
let's talk about x y and z reasons why
this is you know why this game is
easy right now in its current place and
like you know just here in the back and
forth like people were
either really angry or like really like
thank you somebody said it
so like that video is like super not
well received but also very well
received at the same time
the other video that i really liked
making was the other unsolved mystery
video
the unsolved mystery of last exit i
don't know if you remember that puzzle
in destiny 1 but there's that pvp map
where everybody thought there was like
an easter egg and it still hasn't been
found the easter egg on last exit
that video was super fun to make but
other than that it's been like
more of the hardcore community aspect
stuff like
it's really hard for me to
enjoy as much making like the big
kind of story videos when i was there
you know i've been there i've already
i've already experienced the max that
it's going to be
and also it's painful having to go
through like years or maybe
some of the footage you find crazy yeah
that's the impressive part it's like
what you'll find to be like
this clip of like datto talking about
prison of elders i'm like dude he's
going back literally like six years
right now what are you doing so like
that's
yeah that's work he's putting in work
out here so support this man on patreon
he's putting in time
it's definitely big and then the last
one was is there any topic you are
and afraid maybe a strong word but is
there any topic you're
hesitant or afraid to cover i guess is a
way to say it
um a couple of topics first one
i'm always kind of hesitant to talk
about
uh god it's like it's like kind of the
more technical stuff in the game
like hot swapping is one that's like
i don't mind talking about it but people
just get really like heated about it
and like just stuff where it's more
involved like tech wise because i know
not everybody
wants to like learn tech or wants to
learn like the skill curves of
of what a game like destiny can offer
other people get really mad if you talk
about it because they don't want to see
it patched like
if i talk about it bungie's just gonna
patch it so they're like afraid of that
and then like other people get really
really defensive and like
you know we'll try to pickpocket every
thing that i try to say
and they'll pick it apart and they'll be
like hey you got this thing wrong like i
remember i made a
speed run progression video and um there
was just like
so many people that i i called a trick i
said it was like a near-frame perfect
trick
and somebody was like look at how many
frames i can do and i was like okay cool
like thanks man so it's just
it's more stuff like that like number
one and then number two
and this may come as a surprise is lore
i i like talking about the lore in this
game i like to make jokes about it too
and some people get really defensive and
on their high horse about
every little thing like i remember one
time i said um
it was for like the the season 13 recap
because i was trying to make like a
recap video because i've never done one
of those i just wanted to try it
and i made a video about it and i said
that
zavala like this this dude tried to
shoot zabala
and or tried to kill zavala's ghost and
somebody was like
no they were actually trying to kidnap
his ghost with a net and i was like i
was just joking man like
like the whole thing is a joke like like
please like
help me out here so i don't know um
those those two things are mostly what
i'm afraid to like
talk about consistently because it's
just people get really defensive and
really
on their high horse about it and it's
just it's not as fun
it's very good it's very gatekeepy yeah
god forbid somebody talks about all that
stuff right
i just wanted to back up a second
because just you know as far as you know
obviously the content creation we
see that and and the tremendous success
she had there but i did want to ask you
just
with destiny specifically like we see
you know you got this great gaming
history we know you love your souls
games and
sly cooper was in there so some good
some good stuff but i i do
i did want to ask you like the hook of
destiny you know i'm saying like
how did that really cultivate into what
it became now
uh for me it was definitely the
i think like the hook of destiny for me
was always like the mystery aspect
of the game like it was always the idea
that there's something more
and that there's always a challenge to
go with that something more
so like for me the hook of destiny has
always been two main factors
challenge and then loot from that
challenge those
two those two are like so
important to the game and the thing that
i'm kind of finding nowadays with
destiny
and i think why a lot of people are a
little bit hesitant to like
jump back in or a little more critical
about the game like on a day to day
it's cause the game is seven years in to
its life
and like it's hard to come up with new
ideas all the time
and it's and it's really really hard to
consistently
do something that can deliver on like
the scale of the first time you go into
vaulted glass
or can deliver on the scale the first
time you go into shattered throne like
those things are really hard to pull off
um
i do think bungie making the game
more casual is not a bad thing
but it's also not helping them either
right now because i think right now
they're player based they've grown with
the game they understand the game very
well
the people that are playing the game
every season have been playing the game
every season since destiny 1 like they
have their people
now the thing that they need to do now
is to kind of and they're doing it with
vaulted glass having a master difficulty
is to squeeze that challenge just a
little bit harder because
right now players are just slapping
everything that they run into
like we're just kind of running over
things and then it starts to make the
player go
all right we've we've got our god rules
we're bringing them into activities but
and this is
you know i don't mean for this to be
like a negative take about the game but
i also like i i find myself
getting a god roll and then going okay
what's the point of the god rule right
now
because pvp you don't have all these new
maps you don't have modes like stasis
just got fixed which is
in my opinion great um but
like people don't have a place to really
bring their best builds into the game
right now until that challenge is ramped
up
the loot though has been great they've
been delivering on the loot
very nicely now it's just on that
challenge aspect how can you make the
game
significantly harder for people that
have already i mean we've experienced
the game
there's there should absolutely be
options for people
fair enough fair enough i would agree
no i mean i kind of like that because
whether it's been me doing solo
nightfalls are you trying to
go through and do a raid and then it's
like it is the difference of when you
feel contest
and you're like yeah i couldn't you know
it's like templar was tough or didn't
quite get past this one next day it's
just
you're like oh what's up etheon you're
just like casually sitting next to him
he spawns in it's not even the same
encounter 24 hours later and you're like
somewhere
somewhere there's a happy medium in
there even for them to give you
something and master's gonna take that
probably a little more i did want to ask
you though when you come to the
difficulty though
because we played souls games like there
is
and i know they're not gonna translate
one to one i get that so don't somebody
just jump in the comments and crucify me
too so
it's gonna happen already it's fine but
the idea is like the idea of a souls
games it is punishing
there's not a lot of margin for air you
have to learn you're gonna repeat fights
and stuff like that
when it comes to like say a grandmaster
nightfall for a lot of some people
like get through them pretty casually
now depending on how they play but
there's also
the margin for error is small but it's
also like
it's not like i'm focused on somebody on
the ground it's like hey i peeked my
head out and i got
banged by a sniper yeah and it's just
because they're so and it's only because
they're over
leveled use people can go through a
souls game naked
and still technically beat it because it
is doable because the skill is there
like
if you go into you know grand master
naked for one you can't
but two it's just like so when you go
for the difficulty do you like the scale
of difficulty of say a grand master
is there another way you'd like to see
it to go um just obviously because
you've got
kind of a similar background i do yeah
i mean i think with oh god this is like
this is something i think about actually
quite a bit
um grand masters are a really cool idea
and i like that they have like a depth
loot
tied to them like for for beating you
know grand masters but
i also think that grand masters very
much are dependent on
everything else in the game they kind of
they kind of adjust their difficulty
based on everything else so right now
if you think about it the main i guess
i'll start by saying
the main issue with grand masters yes is
the artificial difficulty it's the it's
the fact there's like
contest mode plus all these different
modifiers working against you
but it's also enemy variety enemy
placement is like a huge thing
um when they started introducing master
nightfalls
uh like one of the things that i
remember very clearly was like the
nocris nightfall
you walk in there and instead of like a
wizard being there it's an unstoppable
ogre
that was a really cool use of champions
and like i thought that was really
really nice
um but unfortunately like not all
nightfalls get that same treatment where
it's like they get revamped and they get
like
new enemy variety and placement that
made it interesting to me like i think
one of the things that made strikes
stand out to a lot of people
in destiny 1 more than destiny 2 was
that every year
strikes got a facelift like you would
fight the taken then you'd fight siva
then you you know like and you'd have
different variants that you'd run into
yeah grand masters definitely need to
offer that
variance i'm not saying every time you
load into it enemies need to be
different i'm just saying
compared to the normal strike there
needs to be some sort of new enemy
variety enemy placement
uh enemies need to be hurting you
uh but not just one-shotting you because
the one-shot mechanics i think everybody
is like
all right i died but like come on at the
same time you know
you're like oh i looked the wrong
direction yeah
i was like you can take a couple hits in
a souls game even if you're like okay
that was that was a giant mistake and
i'm scared but not like
i sn i blinked and i'm dead so yeah it's
like
i do like the way you phrased that
though for taking
and that's one thing like strikes in
general i think do need i mean the whole
three core playlist needs some love in
general but i do like how you're saying
the grand masters give some enemy
variety too but more of that as you said
taking a fine please don't take notify
everything though
like the teleporting the teleporting's
got like so when you go into occasional
you're like no stop the overload
captains remind me of that the most the
overload captains when you're doing like
a master lost sector and you're like oh
just stop moving dude
he's just like he's like dude are you on
a pinball machine what are you doing
um so those moments occasionally i get
you i like the i like the idea of the
interviewer hey here's this thing you're
expecting
okay now we can spice it up and honestly
it'd be a point to where
um even like you get to an encounter and
you're expecting hey there's these types
of enemies paired with a whole bunch of
thrall
well what if it is an ogre now with
acolyte so you're saying like ramp it up
give you different variety but also
take the one shot out and give you if
you're gonna throw so much at me you
gotta have a little bit of cover too and
they've gone to these like circular boss
rooms everywhere
so it's like at some point you know
they've gotten away from the cover
because they don't want people sitting
in the back but also
i gotta breathe oh yeah so there's
there's a delicate balance and i know
they're working towards it i'm very
curious for which queen to see what they
do but
i am very very with that
like i think witch queen is the time
that
it's it's kind of the make it or break
it time for for bungie
is the witch queen i think everybody's
kind of not not
hold on not making her not making her
break it
i'm making her break it in the sense
that like hey the game is gonna die you
know
right here it was on june 11th 6 42 pm
now he's been quoted okay
history is
the game's in trouble you heard it here
i agree
no i think so many people
are like okay bungie savithoon
witch queen this has been something that
we've been thinking about since the
taken king was open
this is what we've been thinking about
since the taken king
if you don't deliver on a grand scale
to the like i think no matter what
you've already set yourself up for
disappointment like i think anybody
i i think i think no matter what bungie
has set themselves up for
people to be upset about every little
aspect yada yada
however i think the witch queen will
deliver really well
i think it'll be fun i don't think it's
going to be the
like i i i'm hopeful that it'll be the
technical i'm hopeful that it'll be the
pinnacle of the series i
i for for my career so for all of our
careers sake
but i'm hopeful that it'll be the
pinnacle of destiny
but at the same time i
also am going to be as realistic as
possible and just kind of say
you know it'll be a really fun time but
i don't think it'll be
what like kind of the half-life three
people like the people that want
the perfect game from start defense like
i don't know if it'll be
the elden ring delivery like i don't i
don't know
we don't know until we see trailers i
don't know if we see a trailer this week
or in the next few weeks i don't think
we do
it's like my hunch depending on where
they figure out a date and things like
that
my money is still on game awards cause
it's december
perfect lead into like holiday season
because then they would probably have an
idea when they want to launch it
have enough built and stuff that they
could show that's still my so you can
put a pin in that we'll see if i'm right
or not
um but yeah it's like for me and i kind
of wanted to ask each of you guys the
same thing
i'll start for me witch queen is one of
those things because right now
destiny can easily be a tuesday game if
you want to stream it a lot you want to
do sherpas you want to re you know you
want to do some things
but there's some people who also can
play it on tuesdays and get a lot out of
it the story's really good but the
season only has
so much each season uh vault of glasses
tons of fun
you know depending on if you get vex and
it kind of sucks then you know that
doesn't quite sit as great there's
certain things right now
you know it has its ups and downs for
sure it depends on if you enjoy pvp or
you can't stand it it's a little better
state
um but when it comes to witch queen what
is the biggest thing that you're hoping
for
and again i'm still hoping for like an
armor 3.0
personally because it has been mentioned
there's a point where
it's like i was worried about how many
mods could function on a character maybe
that far out they could make the systems
work better
but for me an armor 3.0 because even now
i get a class sign i'm
like why are you even dropping you need
three class items between now
and um basically which queen
one of each like solar arc and void you
have three class items you're done
like i never need to see a class item
until which queen and then most other
armor ones once you have like
you know master worked your exotics
outside of that there's not a whole lot
of reason for those and the stat
variations you can go for a little bit
here and there but as you said
why would i chase like an armor thing if
i can go you could probably go into or
you know at least with skilled people go
into a grand master
trash stats on your armor but as long as
you even have like some mods equipped to
do it you could probably manage
so like then the point of like how much
armor am i going to grind for
i just want a reason to have the weapons
you said the weapon loot the perks all
that type of stuff has been really cool
to see
the evolution there and hope for more
but the armor is my hope so
for you guys i wanted to ask what's your
what's your one big thing for which
queen that you that's what's like kind
of your top your want list up for
which queen that far out
either of you oh i'm jumping if i was
oh you you got it yeah um yeah i mean
i think for me it's more of a
of a payoff because
narratively because um i think for me i
i need
the the sabbath build up we've been
seeing this this um
the influence that we've been seeing the
last couple of seasons has really ramped
up
and it's it it really has me excited
because i i feel like the narrative team
is probably the best they've ever been
in the history of destiny
and i know that's a big grandiose
statement because people sometimes don't
like the overall state of the game in
pvp and i get that
but lore wise i haven't been this much
into
the story than i you know i've ever been
in and probably in destiny's history so
you know when i felt that way prior was
probably
you know taken king because that was a
very important moment in destiny history
that was to prove that they can
narratively tell a story
right and then cohesively link it
into their in-game content after the
narrative into the raid
right and then post raid right we had
the the taking war and stuff like that
and i i do think it's
there is a lot of pressure i do agree
with evan says there is a lot of
pressure in the sense that
you know we we're coming you know we've
heard about this figure for a long time
with savithoon
we we know lightfall and all that stuff
is after
you know it's supposed to be the
conclusion you know we're getting
towards the end of the uh the light in
the dark saga but we have to wrap this
thing up and
marketing wise i think it's a perfect
opportunity just how they've done
vault of glass in this legends comic uh
comic volt thing
it's a perfect opportunity to bring
king's fall right the season before
right get the marketing buzz going this
is why you love it that's why you
remember
so i think it is important i think it's
it's it's it's important that they nail
it
narratively i it's important that this
savvithune
situation has serious consequences
and and maybe we lose some people you
know obviously been we've been hearing
the rumors about who's on whose side and
who's influenced who's not influenced
and
all this other fun stuff so i think it's
i think it's extremely important now the
key
is going to be the execution the key is
going to be
you know let's be real i'm a var guy but
i respect my king's falls guys like
king's fall is a very tough act to
follow
like that is you know it was what i call
it affectionately a
rage raid right that that so witch queen
in sabbath doing has some
serious things and we're seeing the
rumblings what is it old chicago
we you know we're seeing little things
going on and
i'm excited you know we'll see what
happens i will say this
it is a lot of pressure but for whatever
reason i always feel like
bungie when their backs against the wall
does their best when we're the most
angry with them
they usually come out hey got a lot of
gameplay specialists headed their way
hoplite just got
headed that direction which was awesome
to see she got that role so
they're bringing people in because they
do yeah i know seriously that was
awesome
um they're they're in that moment where
when you see those like gameplay
specialists go out
forsaken stuff like that when the big
changes needed to happen and they need
outside eyes because
right it is the idea of just somebody
from the outside but from the player
base
not the internal testers and everything
else you got to get some outside eyes in
there and it's nice to see some of the
people that are going because
it's good to get a varied perspective
and somebody
they play their game a lot there's no
question like you ask any of them
they're playing all the time
community play there's so many of them
that do but
in turn when it comes to making the new
stuff it's like what do they want so
i'll be very
i'm pumped what about you evan what are
you what are you hoping for out of
which queen what's your top one that you
want to see what topic do you hope to
cover in a future retrospective
well of course i'm looking for like you
know the best raid that they've ever
made and stuff
like that that's that's like a
guarantees that they're gonna make a
great raid
but i also really
really really want to see them overhaul
their leveling system
because it is it is so
boring at this point we've had the same
thing since forsaken
as far as the leveling system like we
can't have another year
of of the same thing and like i think a
lot of people
don't really realize how important the
leveling system is
to the game like this is the first
season where we haven't really had to
care about leveling at all um and i
think people
either really like that and are like
just enjoying that
or you're on the side of okay this is
cool
but now i'm like on week two and i'm i
did the raid
i got my loot that i wanted and now i'm
out and i'll see you in like three
months and like
i don't know if i don't it's a it's a
really hard act to do but i've always
been a knight i've always been an
advocate of
hey the final activities like the raid
dungeons
and um grandmasters or master nightfalls
those should give you materials that
then you use to level up your gear to
then go into certain activities
because that would literally answer that
question that you're talking about about
the class items
like make it so those get capped out and
then all of a sudden hey look
now you have materials that you grind
from playing the end game content that
you can use to level up your stuff
and like you can do that for weapons and
armor they did that in vanilla destiny
one
i don't think people were ready for that
vanilla destiny one i think the
community would be more ready for that
now
but leveling system's a big one raid's a
big one
and then narratively of course they need
to they need to end the story line with
sabbath and we need to kill sabathune
we need to there if if sabathune lives
or sabbath
is like a puppet of the darkness or
something i think people are gonna be
really mad you know like it was all a
dream
no people people are gonna be so mad if
we do not just
ask sabaton in the raid
back to king's fall like back to
ultimate finish
yeah the ultimate finish kill savithune
the raid boss sabathune
because aramis a lot of people are like
just push her off the cliff
what are we doing why don't we leave it
in there she has
this much health you can see it she's
definitely still alive in there
just give her a push and then that's it
that that's all you got to do
let me let me back it up because you
guys break uh good points
in reference to you know you guys
talking really good stuff leveling
system
armor 3.0 like i want to give it back to
eagles i know he he always talks about
it but it's like
i need to know specifics like do you
want them to i know i know we're big
fans of outriders in terms of how they
handle gear right and how they handle
you like yeah it started well let's just
leave it there
it started well it started well you know
the fabled destiny killers that start
well
but the thing is like what that we've we
learned right the appreciation
for every boot and every armor every
gear
every headpiece there was some
association shout out to slo-mo's in the
chat he's a division guy right
you know what we love about division is
you know the armor sets and
stat bonuses and like do you want
do you want that you wanted to mimic any
of those type of systems
i mean what i would i love i love that
literally a mix of what you and evan
both said
would be cool so some way for one
like coming from a world of warcraft
background which i know everybody hates
but but luke likes that's that luke
loves that yeah and i was like you know
scary i want to talk about luke stuff
right
but it is the idea that you could be
level 60 say you know in world of
warcraft take
our level 1300 for example and you could
get a piece of gear that would be say 55
stats
in a normal strike say then you go into
nightfalls now your gear can drop up to
a certain level
could maybe have another assault like
slot for more mods
like you get to a point where the more
difficult the activity
opens up more possibilities and also
what evan was saying
so set bonuses would be that'd be
amazing like you go into vanguard
strikes you're working through hey i got
the vanguard set bonus strike
that one helps out my character do more
you know maybe the vanguard is a bit
more defensive
minded because you picture zavala as
your guy and you've got a little more
defensive minded to it maybe
a crucible set bonus builds in mobility
and stuff because you want to be moving
faster things of that nature gambit
that one's going to be about killing
mobs because you're killing them all the
time maybe the raids that
like set bonuses they teased at one
point with the
with the uh season of the prime yeah i'm
like they teased them like
that stuff can function and then they
stripped it away and took away all my
hope and i was like so mad
so set bonuses yeah i was like set
bonuses would be amazing but also the
idea of that top level activity either
giving you a way to
push your gear higher as he as evan said
with some type of currency
that you earn to say hey maybe if you
you know go through the raid 10 times
you get this thing
and now you can unlock an extra mod slot
or take your energy on a piece of armor
from 10 to
14 so you can have a lot more you some
way to push your character up
by putting time into those in-game
activities because as evan said
even if you do the master like vault of
glass when it comes out
and you get a time lost weapon that
might have a couple different perks
there's really not going to be a lot
again that sets much of what
what you're going to get apart and it's
going to be difficult to get
but it's not going to be much it's the
juice should be worth
the squeeze and that's the thing is like
the end game
tough challenges you know if you solo
master like solo flawless a master
dungeon
you better get something good for that
otherwise why am i doing it
say all of that but yeah set bonuses
would be amazing to see
and then some way to set your either
earn and push the gear higher or if you
do
a you know a master raid your gear can
now drop with 12 energy 13
14 energy and you can have more
flexibility in the mod slots or give me
another mod slot or both
find some way and they may be worried
about like you know certain things but
god forbid now i could use
what if i could use two like champion
mods
and a reload mod at the same time like
oh god like
i'm gonna break the game but just the
idea that i could go earn something that
gives me that flexibility
then you could actually see a reason to
be like hey this allows you to build
even deeper i feel like that's that's
what i want out of the army
if that makes sense i mean you witness
where you at man
i'm definitely like i'm definitely on
the side of set bonuses
i'm still very much on the like there's
still that part of my brain that like
set bonuses are fantastic and i think
it'd actually create good build variety
it would actually make people like step
out of their shell as far as like
transmog like transmog you can enjoy
and then also have set bonuses so like
it would actually give you a reason to
rock it like just like raid gear but
just like raid gear
there's no reason until the game
actually starts challenging its player
base on these high-end scales
there's no reason for this stuff until
they make something that is challenging
to the overall like
majority of the player base i know that
sounds like just some people who are
listening like that sounds like a messed
up statement hey this is
very challenging for me this i'm not
necessarily calling out a single
individual
i'm saying on a general level everybody
in this game
hits that point you know you play it
long enough or maybe you haven't played
it that long and you just got
you just happen to know your loadouts
what you're rocking
and you beat a thing and you're like man
that was cool
now i want more and it's like where does
that more come from
does it come from the idea of going back
into the raid and beating atheon with
sidearms
or does it come from the fact that when
i go into that raid
that raid is very hard it is like
contest levels of difficulty
so let me have things that just push me
over the line just
that little bit more and that's where
set bonuses could shine
but the thing is we need the game to be
leveling wise and difficulty wise on a
general scale
more challenging because they have got
really good with loot and story they've
gotten a lot better with
and they've gotten a lot better like
they've gotten a lot better in a lot of
aspects
the one thing they're missing right now
is that challenge
is that like final push like hey
let's get this game to be much harder
and that i'm not i'm not asking for
something that's on the level of
bloodborne or dark like i'm not asking
for that it's the same
i know now i know i i i know not
everybody
i know not everybody's like with that
but at the same time
there needs to be that option for the
witch queen where people can go
damn that was hard i'm i'm with you this
yeah
we got at first i was nervous because i
was like i was like i know how bungee
thinks
in my opinion lately with this increased
engagement
and getting more of the casual bass in
and not turning them away
but you just nailed it with the last
thing you said which is
again like for example you know when we
had contest mode right and then it goes
away
right but why not have that those type
of things as a more these difficulty
levels
where the reward now matches
the level of difficulty you're
attempting so that you get these
materials you
get these adept weapons you get the
higher chances of fatebringer and vex to
drop
because you are now challenging yourself
at this heart of difficulty
and just in general like or if they're
going to have difficult content
you put those exclusive rewards because
we could people can play all they want
but
let's be real when crucible and glory
mode
had mountain top recluse in there
yep we were in there yeah absolutely i
see
my man e in there with a grenade
launcher
i'm playing with him and he is bee
lining to the special
bed the the heavy oh no i got very good
with fighting lion that's what i did
yeah you would like beat like so at the
end of the day
as much as i know a lot of community
they get mad about it but
it made you push it made you i was like
into these activities to take that even
deeper there was
vault of glass also was kind of special
because
the only way to get max level was to
raid
you had to do the end game activity to
reach max level
and now you can trip into it right like
that piece as well i don't know if
that's in any other game like
how do you get to paragon level 50 and
diablo go get your ass killed and
probably paragon 48 49ers i don't know
even how those work haven't played in so
long but
like that's the idea is like have the
challenge be the thing that gets you
there and that's the incentive to be
like
all right i'm a kind of at next level i
know that if there's no carrot out there
people aren't gonna go look and try and
find a way to do it
the carrot has to be there
the best thing that i can use as an
example going off of that is like
that feeling of forever 29 that destiny
won vanilla had
a lot of people meme on it but like
realistically
when you were 29 the raid was still very
very hard
and then once you hit level 30 the raid
it didn't become easy but it became
all right now i'm at the level of the
raid and that's
that was something that i think a lot of
people slept on
i think that that part of it was like
why was vlog so hard why was it so
memorable why
was it just the loot no it wasn't just
luke because if you ran into
if you ran into vog and you got
fatebringer of course that's amazing
but if there's nothing challenging that
fatebringer makes a little easier on
your life
then vog becomes not as cool so like
going into the raid
getting your butt kicked by some
praetorians that are leveled like 27
and you're level 25 or 23 and just like
getting rolled by them that was
that at overcoming that challenge that
was the part that i think a lot of
people
really did enjoy with vog and i think
like
that's the part of like why did you have
to push atheon off the map was it
because it was fun
yeah but it was also but it was also
because atheon was so hard for people
early on
that they went dude let me push him off
the map i can't beat this
like that was so when they eventually
like that's that's what i'm trying to
say
that's the
um especially this past two seasons has
been great
and uh the story has been getting
significantly better
like all those things have been you've
been crushing it on that now
incentive challenge and rewards for that
challenge and incentive
absolutely that's all it is i'm with you
on incentive because again
you put that difficulty in there you put
that challenge in there
please reward that base
that put in that extra effort you want
they should be
shining in the tower when i see those
guys that's what made me love destiny
yeah i see those guys at the top like
yo what what is that you see the raid
uniform you see
you know the kings fall with the glow i
want dramatic over-the-top
showering i want number one things fall
with the
with the horns and the chroma yeah i
mean the age of triumph still the best
for sure
age of triumph was the best like i
remember doing eighth yard they had the
wi-fi antenna on top of the head
i'm like what is that like why
i became an osiris fan but i was like yo
what is this egyptian gear that people
are wearing
how do i get this i want to be a part of
this
you know what i'm saying so you just
like the gear not the man i'm just
kidding
he got he got good clothes
one too many supreme shopping trips
but yeah but like literally it's that
kind of stuff
and and again you know what even with
the glory when they introduce glory
and recluse and mountain top you're like
yo i got i gotta get my behind and glory
i gotta get in there man
so go over the top with it reward the
base they will be happy
you will then push people past their
little comfort zone and then like you
said
you you became a good fighting lion
player
oh no i honestly never like brutal
grenade launchers like god these are
awful
and then i had to learn to use them for
mountaintop and
honestly now like salvage or salvo dude
i probably piss people off with that
thing i know
everybody hates those to a passion right
now but
like if you just have never used one and
picked it up you're probably gonna be
terrible
but if you use those for a while
especially now like that they're
actually in a decent space in salvage
versus chain reaction
like mods that make it really cool
they're fun i wish
i wish they didn't cost nine energy and
seven energy to use some of their mods
but they're still fun
yeah yeah the okay i'm going to say this
now is my last thing
which queen let me open the whole
boop i'm going to center myself artifact
the whole artifact
don't limit me to 12. let me have every
mod you already make them too expensive
i can't combine things
let me have all of them because there's
no reason i would be like
which what which is the last two that i
pick i could experiment with the other
ones later on
no i'm okay with that however
okay only the guy will say they'll make
it extreme insanely long
i'm with that all i'm saying is if they
don't i'm with you if they do that great
if they don't do that there's this game
called outriders right
and when i make a mistake as far as my
skills
just let me reset the undo button and
the game is going to
watch me and then double exponentially
every time i want to read it okay then
that yeah if just reset skill trees all
the time yeah just do that just be like
you got 12 reset undo reset under just
do whatever you want sure
bro shout out the cool guy he got a good
video right now right um
it's the uh it's the oh it's a good mod
man it's uh oh yeah
impulse recycler right i didn't even
know about this
grenade energy it is an amazing amount
he's got these things where you're
getting grenades and super energy
because of this build right i've already
reset my damn artifact like three
sorry it's gonna cost me over 80 000
glimmer like
why and then there's a cap on glitter so
i'm like why
why but let me play and tweak with your
game like you
you have it there i don't understand
what is the mentality by penalizing me
to reset an artifact that you make
available for the season to
to try to introduce different play
styles but you may penalize me so that i
can't do it
like that got to change so i'm with you
with this artifacts that either
let us rock out just whatever you want
remove the cost yeah one of the two
i agree yeah you can unlock you'll say
maybe only 12 is the number you can have
unlocked
reset and pick them again so you have
the same requirements but let me do it
anytime i want to
that's sorry i just thought of that and
had to scream it again so if bungie ever
hears one of these just
please take the cost out there's no
reason for that
you heard him what about you evan before
you got anything else you want before we
kind of head into
more of the recent activities since
we've been future and past so far
um i'll say one thing that's really
important for destiny like
myself i i okay
when when i'm done with grand masters
when i'm done with strikes and i'm done
with gambit when i'm done with raids and
i'm done with the whole game
a big part of getting the god roll is
pvp and i know a lot of people don't
really like pvp and destiny
i really do because it's just it's gun
play it's fun like it's fun shooting
people
but realistically
maps and game modes we just need
more that's that's kind of it like like
honestly that's
that's another big thing that we are
currently
missing pretty badly and i i have a
feeling that they're gonna bring more in
the future like i don't think they're
gonna completely ignore it forever or
else they wouldn't have spent
what this entire season like revamping
stasis they wouldn't have spent time
making pvp changes all over the place
with snipers
shotguns and then i think they said
something about trials getting a rework
at some point in the next year so like
they're not ignoring it but at the same
time
we're so hungry for a pvp map a new pvp
mode because i
really enjoy what they did with scorched
and if they want to keep doing stuff
like that where it's like
crazy this or that like fly across the
mouth like that was cool
just give me more maps to just
experiment with like we just got this
huge
winter beautiful planet europa or i
guess
yeah we just got we just got europa yeah
no man i i want to see a map in the
clovis brave facility
i want to see a map out you're so clean
yeah
like how how was gambit how was that not
done
that that to me is like gambit needs
some maps because gambit is actually
people forget gamut's actually waited
longer than crucible for new maps
gambit hasn't got a new map since gambit
prime came out they take maps away from
gambit
yeah they took two away and you still
have maps on other pla you still you can
still go to mercury
when it comes to crucible but gambit had
to lose two maps and you're like
why it already is painful enough why is
the dreaming city gambit map gone
like that map the dream city is still
here so like that
that stuff for me that that's another
big one it's like
because that's my final place that i go
when i'm when i'm like bored and i'm
like
ready to just i still want to play
destiny
yeah exactly like like we're just
because we're looking for something to
like
constantly keep our brain active and
constantly have fun in the game and so
maps like crucible is like such an
important part of like what keeps the
game going
past the first three two months of
people playing it
can you imagine like paintball in the
vex network
a map in there
if we got a pvp map based around each
seasonal activities kind of
area every single season that would be
awesome even if it's just one like that
would be so cool because then people
would be like oh look at this little
spot that i learned look at this little
cool thing
you know one thing that because i cuz i
love playing like right now i play a lot
of valor
i love i love valerian i love those
types of tack shooters they're so much
fun
um one of the things that like i've
learned with destiny is that
i mean they have a lot of geometry
things where they just decide to put
like a tree branch there for no reason
you're like oh i just tripped on this
branch what's going on but like
i know i love having map variety and i
love
all the movement and gunplay options we
get in this game
just give me more pvp maps and i'm i'm
there i'm there for literally
i'm with you which 100 we don't have to
go
battlefield size but also a little
bigger size so you can have some room
for
stuff to breathe oh for sure like like a
map that
allows me to actually use scout rifles
other than dmt effectively
you know yeah like a map that is more
placated to
close range long range like all these
things and there's a lot of balancing
things that have to come into the game
of course like we have
we have really fast movement compared to
destiny one so just
new maps that are just awesome to just
mess around with is all i'm looking for
for the pvp side obviously anti-cheat
but i think that's
i i saw rumors that something like that
is coming like i saw they were hiring
somebody for it
yeah i saw job postings that said like
anti-cheat
battle eye and i was like oh
i was like whoa
maybe the destiny 2 pvp overseer they're
the omniscient eye they can see all
things
oh you've got an accuracy of 98
somebody just gets the band hammer
yeah i mean witch queen is as you said
like
when you get into a season outside of
the tuesday story and then after about
week eight or so it's like
you can check out for like two months
and then now
for this final season 15 if we're
guessing i keep guessing like february
you're talking seven eight months
i don't i don't want them to stretch a
story like do their eight weeks of this
do you know get your season and then you
know let crossplay fill in some of the
gaps and things like that that's going
to be coming which is awesome
but yeah it's like we've got a ways to
go so it's like if
i again i i keep saying at this point
witch queen
is a big deal so if they take longer to
do it right
i am okay with that that's that's kind
of where i'm at for it because it need
it at this point as you're saying
we need pvp maps i wanna like you know
more challenge i want some
armor we have different decent sized
ones these are not small things these
are system level changes
take the time you need to build them so
that way you can kick this final trilogy
off in the best way possible
oh yeah second guaran i can guarantee
you when people are like
hey man like i i really liked the witch
queen it was super fun
um but now i'm just kind of like bored
i'm just kind of sitting here like you
know
i played it for two months three months
like however a month whatever
whatever somebody like likes to play in
the game i guarantee you they're like
well what is pvp like right now it's
like oh
you know stasis got fixed so it's a lot
better but
at the same time there's not really any
new maps and there hasn't been for
600 days so like and let's be real yeah
no incentive no incentive for it yeah
yeah what what's in there
like treat treat pvp
in the same way you treat pve where
there is in-game
content where there is true rewards to
to go after and again that's that's why
i really missed the uh what is it that
used to be pinnacle rewards what
what were they considered they were
because they were pinnacle gear yeah
mountaintop
let's bring it back you know you know i
i i
it just baffles me because you know evan
said it best like
we're going to get to that point where
you you you do all the seasonal stuff
you do all the
you get the weapons you you you farmed
your god rolls in override
you got everything done and then pvp and
game
these are the most to supplement to keep
us engaged
when that stuff is done you know what
i'm saying so now i'm like okay i'm
working on my glory now i'm doing this
okay bring it back they got to and i
just don't understand
even if the forge even though we know
the maps is the biggest
like offense we get that but there's
still no reason to go in there unless
you're like a fan of the gun play like
how
me and evan are you just love the com
the competitive and
in the shooting aspect they still needs
to be in instead of remember when
malfeasance was in gambit i don't know
how long ago that was god
like seriously yeah that bro where are
the exotic quest
tied to pvp to give pvpers that love i
remember randy's throwing knife and
where is this stuff like it's it's
really bad
they gotta get on that man incentive
incentive incentive
for sure well that definitely covers a
few things that we'd like to see in the
game all right bunji you have your work
there's homework go ahead and knock it
all out no no no worries you got plenty
of time
um but this week obviously we got iron
banner back
uh i wanted to see how you guys had if
you put any tyrant time
into it if you got any awesome rolls
how's it feel with that stasis have you
even seen stasis
uh or is it kind of gone were you guys
that on iron banner or stasis nerfs and
just kind of this week
how you feeling um i think
like i actually got lucky the last iron
banner i got
a four out of five shotgun and i was
like all right you know i don't
i was like i got surplus iron reach
assault mag and like
whatever the barrel was that like
everybody wants i was like you know
i'm good like i'm good with the shotgun
like i got it already
um so i got really lucky but iron
banner's been fun like it's it's always
fun to just go in and just
like just shoot people but at the end of
the day i'm also really happy that
there's not as much stasis
like i'm happy i'm not getting frozen
oh yeah pour one out for stasis being
gone like crab rave it up for stasis
being gone but
what else is this a beat saber band here
oh yeah we're crab raven oh
nice i feel like i feel like hunter
stasis is still there because hunters
are still like
you know people are people right now
they're reacting the fact that stacey's
got nerf so they're like all right i'm
not gonna play stasis but hunter states
is still very powerful
warlock stasis is still pretty powerful
titans got
nuked yeah and
i'm i'm i'm fine with it i'm very like
oh my god i can play striker titan oh my
god i can play
anything else besides stasis without you
know and it's funny because
trials i feel way more in trials now i'm
like oh man you can't freeze me and then
slide into me
man wow let's see how you actually can
shoot and then i just run somebody over
like it's just
it's so much nicer i go through the game
so much quicker and
it's very obvious you know to the to the
adapt crowd just adapt to stasis it's
very obvious that
the adapting was not an actual
like it didn't work out the way that i
think people in that in that kind of
base who were like hey just adapt to
stasis just get used to it's like
you can't adapt to a movement shooter
being completely frozen
for like five seconds at a time like you
can't adapt to that
i mean emtash literally quit the game
because stasis was just ruining his fun
yeah he still isn't even officially
really back no
he's just he's not because he's just
like you know what
stasis it just ain't it for me and i
mean i have a very
cynical take on stasis that like i i
know not everybody's gonna agree with
but i also think like business side
the way that like i'm thinking about it
with stasis i think stasis was pushed
out
that powerful in an attempt to sell a
lot of copies of beyond light to
free-to-play players because
what's gonna suck is getting frozen by
somebody because like i don't think if
you're a
developer you looked at stasis and went
yeah that's the stuff right there i
don't think any like
game dev looked at stasis and was like
yep that's the stuff
i think i was like did you guys say
did either of you guys catch the firing
range this past week
i didn't get to listen to the full thing
but i've heard like little snippets of
it yeah basically it was like kevin
yanus came out and said they wanted
stasis to be a
defensive subclass to give you time to
move and react which is where some
people feel it kind of may be closer to
now for some classes
but they also said when it launched
they're like yeah that's gonna have to
come down about four times
they knew when it was going out the door
yep they knew 100
knew going out the door because yeah it
was like they
well they said at first like you could
slow somebody down but you couldn't hurt
them
and you're like well this doesn't feel
good you're just delaying the action
so then they had to crank it up and
crank it up and crank it up and they're
like oops
but it was by the time they cranked it
up it was time to send it so no i
yeah there's there's a weird thought
process around how stasis was sold
developed shipped six months later
working on nerfing again and again and
again after like the
community like every person i know in
the community
should like slow it down shut it down
they're so happy to nerf some things
into the ground quickly but that one's
been like
now we're gonna go little by little but
then rocket launchers take 18 months to
get the buff so
it's really really weird the way stasis
went sorry i think like
i there's i like i think that's to me
that's developers speak for we knew it
wasn't ready
like we knew we weren't happy with it
but we also kind of got told to make it
the most powerful um because like that
to me
reads is like okay boss said
stasis needs to be very strong and
oh my god we're on it we're out of time
we have to delay this even more oh no we
we've already delayed the game three
months
for beyond light so now let's just let's
just push it out
you know they're not gonna be happy with
it at first let's start working on it
but like
i also am very much of the mindset that
the developers at bungie they're not
they're not dumb people they understand
what they're doing
they they wouldn't yeah they wouldn't be
in the position that they're in
however i think marketing team and
business team was like hey man
um
yes i'm with you i hate to cut you
because you won't fire you'll fight
right now
that's that's what i mean though it's
like i i really think and it's i don't
mean that to be like a
a mean sentence i don't mean that to
attack anybody but that's just business
sense that's just how
the company is gonna go that's why in
this actually teaser for the next video
that i'm doing for youtube but
in the next video i'm talking about the
forsaken armor exotics like when they
first came out
and like just how powerful those were in
pvp and just like
people forget that you were in super
forever people forget that like
you had infinite supers pretty much for
everything if you got lucky enough to
get it
but like that was also very clearly in
an effort to sell forsaken to people who
like played destiny one year one and
we're like
yeah so like it's it's not something new
to the series
release it strong take care of it later
that's what i'm trying to tell people
like i
it's the the pattern repeats itself too
much evan is on
fire i've been telling people this
is what happened is the developers who
we yell at
that are not stupid yeah they understand
what they're doing
they know the structure of how this
thing is going to play
this is their game but then there's
corporate and marketing and business and
and how do you sell the new dl's the new
expansion for destiny
about freezing right you you gotta sell
this thing to get
the casual audience to be like oh wow
i'm actually gonna trick
play this and i could compete cause i
could freeze the top player
and you know say i'm in the mix and all
this stuff
and the same thing i literally said this
when um what is it what is it transmog
yeah we know every other
game it hits you this is a feature that
should not cost anything that should not
be this
complicated right but in my opinion
again marketing said look you know they
wanted this thing for a long time
right but we got to figure out how to
monetize this you got to figure out
you cannot give them car blanche all the
gear they want
right so put a cap on that give them
about four five
four five for the season and then we'll
deal with the aftermath
later that is the business side of
destiny that i feel
always comes in and that's why i don't
go crazy on them anymore
because i know like i said we shoot
firing range
and you hear the comments from the
developers say oh no no we knew that
thing was busted
at lawrence but we wouldn't you know
we'll deal with the repercussions later
and if you notice like you said evan
things at launch always tend to be
op first it's rare
when you get something like damn like i
can count on my head like
maybe this season you could say vex with
the class that needs to get up right
i could i could think about that one
time when xenophage did came and we're
like yeah that's weird
uh it's terrible right now it's amazing
what i'm saying it's but it's very rare
normally it's like whatever say where
you know remember what was supers all
day wait what is it uh skull armor
all the super generating stuff oh yeah
that builds up hype and you get the
casual the guy to get in there
and feel powerful and that's the guy
that they want they don't
never say they don't care about the
hardcore but they want more engagement
for new players that's what's going to
get
the business model popping and you put
these flashy things
it gets people excited and then they'll
deal with the repercussions later and
they'll nerf later they'll patch later
and i've
always said cause it's this cyclical
history that always repeats itself it's
not out
it's not a chance this is this is the
struggle internally with the studio
and i i firmly believe that yeah
i i mean that's perfect like well
very very well said it's just like i
think
it's not a bad thing to know that
to be aware of business-wise what's kind
of happening
however if you're bungee you got to be
like you got to be a little bit more
subtle
about how you approach your business
aspect because we shouldn't be sitting
here as players being like
ah yes i know exactly how they're doing
this because of marketing x
y and z it's like uh we should probably
give people what they want for a little
bit and then sell because like they're
gonna buy it either way cause we love
destiny like this game is so special the
the universe is wonderful but like um
i i just i find myself with these type
of topics like i
i love the developer commentary that
like firing range was able to do like i
i
love that type of stuff because it's
just you get to hear what they're
thinking and where their perspective is
where they're coming from
um i just i really wish i
really wish that things came out the
of course things are gonna come out the
gate kind of more powerful but i wish
they weren't just like
hey we broke the game we'll fix it in
three months like
i would much rather it be like hey
it's it's a little bit more powerful
than what you're used to but it's not
broken like
vex mythoclast is a little underwhelming
to what people wanted
i haven't used it yet but i've heard
that it's kind of underwhelming
yeah tassie got it was just like nah
this ain't it
chief so like should vex be
where it was when it first came on
destiny one no oh god no that thing
would break the game
but should vex be a
you know worse version of terrible from
like crown of sorrow
probably not either so like i think
they're i i think asda cross made a
video on like that bungie is thinking
about buffing vex with the class which
is good
i would rather things just come out in a
sense of like it has a purpose it's
going to fulfill that purpose
instead of like it's going to break the
game or it's going to be tremendously
underwhelming
yeah i mean you're okay i mean the thing
is it's such a tough thing because
you know on iron lord's podcast we get a
lot of you know developers and we'll get
like guys like jason schreier
and you start to see how to how the cake
is made
right you start to learn things about
development and here's the thing where
i've learned to calm down on them
as a gamer i i would say kind of things
you were saying like yo what they know
what this is bro well they know this is
messed up
what what the hell you know saying what
the hell buddy what's wrong with you and
the thing about game that i've game
development that i've learned
is there's that constant battle because
you've got the developer and then you've
got
the publisher so to speak right and in
bungie's case
they're independent now right so when
before it was activision and all that
other stuff
now it's on them so now they remember in
the past
we always used to be like that damn
activision they're the one making these
decisions and
making it and then we come to find out
oh well well well it ain't just acting
because tess is out here
moving and shaking since activision's
been gone right
so the reality is there's still the
business side
right and there's still these the
sustainability of the game
and one thing i try to calm down i'm
like okay look
they're on their own they do need to
make revenue they do need to figure this
out
and it's that it's that constant balance
right but i will give bungie this credit
most games i'm looking at you outriders
um they don't listen after a while and
they are
dug in looking at you marvel avengers
awesome
probably worse decisions where the
entire community is like
what are you doing and they say we're
not playing anymore
one thing about bungie about them being
analytic driven
is when they start seeing the retraction
of people out of that
the crucibles all that stuff that i'm a
firm believer evan
that one of the reasons that stasis
nerf was pushed up because remember they
told us we were supposed to get that for
a while
yeah they had to see those numbers they
had
to see what is going on and when we
played black
that's how we fight them because we're
like yo they're saying it i'm out you
see m tags like
i'm out there's a lot of people i'm not
dealing with this this is not it
and then because i think the the
business of engagement is still
important in live service and i think
that's what it is so it's a healthy it's
a balance they have to flirt
but in their defense i will say they
generally
usually at some point finally do listen
and try the correct course and make
right we just
tired of the the the cycle yeah
yeah it's like it's it continues to be
the cycle of destiny 2 is going to come
out with double primaries and of course
they can reinvent the game is the best
expansion ever for destiny 2.
so again it's like yeah we'll go through
the cycles it seems to be
just seems to be a trend like the ups
and downs of destiny is probably going
to be
what you could write literally title
your book about this thing by the time
it's all said and done
pretty much i'll just literally call it
the experience of destiny
this is why people love to hate this
game that's why people
hate to love this game i love the meme
that's like
oh you're talking bad about dusty and
you're you're a player oh yeah you can
laugh about it all you want somebody
who's never played destiny and they gave
him a crap
you can't do that that's only for us
that one kills
you so bad because it's so accurate be
like oh you haven't
lived in the blood sweat in two years of
destiny you can't give it crap you
haven't been here but i've been through
it so i can give it hell it's like
it's a weird thing but it's oddly
accurate
and to you guys credit who runs
successful channels
let's be honest destiny gives us stuff
to talk about
oh mm-hmm it is part of its longevity is
this
crazy history right you got evan you
know doing these historical pieces about
the time when destiny did this so when
it's just there's always something to
talk about
and e like the nerfs the buffs to this
that it
it's a game it weirdly it's
self-promotion and
self-marketing by all this craziness
that goes on with the game
the ups and the downs well i think
yeah no go ahead no i i fully agree with
that i think
uh you know as long as there's more
stuff for me to talk about with the game
i'll be making videos on the game
you know that's pretty much my rule of
thumb yeah
um but i wanted to ask you guys as for
this week's expunge mission if you had a
chance to
jump into it and also kind of the lore
and story this week with uh
um reality hitting one of our npcs
pretty hard so i wanted to see if you
guys had any thoughts about
basically where the story is going uh so
far if you guys have any hunch of where
it could be leading and just kind of
where you feel it's at this week and
cool stuff
and if you had a chance to run that
expunge mission
uh yeah i've uh i've i ran the expunge
mission i thought it was really cool
um i thought like they used some new
mechanics which like i haven't seen them
used before and i'm like i'm like okay
cool like i'm i'm happy with that i
thought the mission was
well done i think all the expunged
missions have been very well done
they've been
they do exactly what destiny should do
it's a good mix of
time time management platforming and gun
play
and that's like to me that's always
where destiny
like activity wise is at its best is
when
you know you're managing your gun play
well you're also managing your time well
like that's why
people really like like the zero hours
like the whisper missions because it's
like
time but also platforming but also
clearing tough enemies like
that's and i think expunge is a good
like little sample of that
um as far as story goes i i have a
feeling that like
we're gonna see some sort of some sort
of fighting or some sort of war
with like lakshmi and mythrax because
like
lakshmi clearly does not like mythrax or
the fallen at all
and everybody else is like get with the
program old lady and she's like
nah and like i i have a feeling like
we're seeing some kind of turmoil like
about to kind of be ready to
to pop at some point so we'll see i mean
i'm
i'm excited and we still got what two
months left in the season
a month august 24th so
two months yeah two and a half in two
months yeah yeah we got and we've only
got
probably because you're going to have
the challenges for vaulted glass
launching next week we're gonna have
a few more weeks of expunge but you've
got quite a few weeks left in the season
right so we have like a lot to kind of
go over before we even get to the
before we even get to a potential like
you know crazy moment but i have a
feeling it's gonna be
more back and forth more like you know
more more [ __ ] talking from one to
another and you know just like
constant like back and forth and i i
mean i don't know i think it's i think
they're doing a really good job
this is the first season because i know
a lot of people say last season
storywise was like awesome
but last season we sat at a table and
watched like a projector
kind of talk to us about stuff this is
the first season where we're
constantly seeing fighting and i think
there's a good interesting storyline
because i think all of us
internally knew that kaido coming here
we were probably going to
team up with kaido like i think
everybody kind of like just guessed that
that was going to happen
there was going to be no consequences of
that i think this time
this is so like holy crap like it's
actually happening like there is this
house of light that we thought was going
to come with
outbreak at some point like you know
yeah yeah like it's finally happening
and
we're seeing things but we don't
necessarily know the payoff yet we don't
know that yet
and i think we knew with season of the
chosen where the payoff was going to be
where it was going to land
and i don't think we know necessarily
where this is going to land yet
good point true yeah what about you cog
where you been yeah i agree i think it
is this is that
the beauty of the season lore wise is
literally what evans said that
the uncertainty right of how this is
gonna play out because
you know latch me let's be honest we
haven't seen her in such a long time so
for her to come back
and be such a divisive force at the
tower which i think is brilliant like i
just i love the writing
it really mirrors a lot of real world
scenarios as far as like
you know immigrants yeah like you know
crossing borders and all this other
stuff and mithrax has been in this weird
position where he's trying his best
to really keep it together even though
his people are
you know really getting a lot of you
know against them with the ether tanks
the following but i did the expunge
i agree with i thought the expungement
was really good this week a nice cool
mechanics
the way you you did the the um finding
the boxes and then
trying to unlock the puzzles while the
things are coming at you thought that
was well done
you know and then we got like you said
he the uh
we wonder why satan was quiet last week
yeah
and uh yeah he had a lot of reflection
and it was a really it was really well
done
you go speak to him in the tower and
he's really solemn
he's really looking at a self you know
analysis of himself as as a monster and
you know one thing what they did very
well with his character
is when they brought him in you know
he's rough and tough saint we all know
that right
but one thing about him when you play
trials and stuff he's always on the
children they love when they laugh and
the children everything is the children
right
and it bothered him when the fallen
babies and they were they were like they
were running they were scared
that's a big thing with his character
he's like nightmare fuel to them and
yes they were terrified they were
terrified and he he talked about it
the the self-analysis was really good
you know we go back and
i'll see you know laxmi still stirring
the damn pot
cora had her her conversation yeah girl
though
yeah i leave you on that icy moon you
keep running your mouth
i thought that was like i thought that
was perfect she's like she could nova
bomb her pretty much out of existence
but i like
more of the like isolationist punishment
like uh
a spy that screws up and gets stuck in a
like a radar tower in alaska or
something
the same idea i was like that's kind of
perfect i i love that
so the warning was given you know and
you know we got to see it it it could go
so many ways i'm very curious to see the
resolution that definitely the conflicts
coming
i want to know what's going on i want to
know about the osiris theory what's
going on with him
was you know his motivations or not
motivations
and then obviously um crow and zavala so
we we got some loose ends the top a
couple more weeks but i
every week i look forward to doing the
expunge getting the info
seeing where this thing go but what
about you like any standouts
was it the same thing that got you or
just in general the same thing was
the same thing was really good just to
see his character even ruku had a good
point it's like that saint never got the
chance to
adapt to basically the transition of
what we've been going through post
golden age because he died long before
d1 ever started
it's like the stuff that we've been
going through the gods that we've killed
the challenges that we've gone through
in the tower and
not the tower and all of the things
we've done and changes we've seen and
he hasn't been around for a lot of that
so it's actually that's a really good
point
but also the fact that you said when you
know that
the licks need children the hatchlings
however you want to call them whatever
age they are
they look at saint as literally the
boogeyman and they see
him as just literally the epitome of
fear
so when they see him walking around on
patrol they're like
um sorry that's the dude in our like
scary books and he's just what
like that's that's gotta be terrifying
that'd be like me walking around the
grocery store
and literally just looking at like just
some
terrifying game like you know just
something it's the cheetah he's here
yeah it's just like but that's like a
really cool way to
humble somebody really fast and actually
make you empathize with for one what
he's doing
to kind of what it is like for the house
of light they didn't do anything wrong
fallen in turn are you know they've been
our enemy and obviously he fought them
and in his mind
he's protecting the city but them
they're trying to get to the traveler so
it's like
it's been really cool i would say the
best thing has been seeing the
perspectives this season
i think is what i've really enjoyed with
the story is getting getting the outside
perspectives getting
lakshmi's perspective because she's
seeing something so it's all
yeah she's she's but she's like she
looked into her thing and she was like
before i didn't say anything and the red
war came and you know we lost our power
and almost lost the entire tower we did
lose the tower because we're sitting on
a shelf now
um so she's scared like what she saw
doesn't matter
and now if she doesn't say anything but
you know like then in turn it's out of
context is
myth rex in the burning city
oh yeah the vision that she had yeah
yeah is it something
that's like is it is he helping is he
hurting is he the one that caused it is
he trying to like save people and
we don't know much context around that
so again it's like a lot of things
without all the details around it so
i think this has been like the season of
perspective has been like a really
really cool one to kind of be part of
and i think the way
i was listening to dcp um
and i think the way they always phrase
it's like part of the issue with destiny
sometimes feels like i get the page in
the mail a week for the book i'm reading
yeah the way they tell the story every
week is like i get the page in the mail
a week i'm like this is it
but it's also the idea of the tv shows
that you find successful
are the ones that you do get the episode
every week so you can talk about what's
going on as opposed to
the netflix show that dumps all you know
season you binge it
is cool it's reviewed and then it's done
as opposed to the weekly discussion like
we have right now and i was like
that's a good point i actually had not
thought about that and i was like
and as evan said long time ago the way
they're doing the story this season more
in-game more like the actual other space
that we've got not just the holographic
projection which was cool a step in the
good direction but this season
nah it's like this one i do enjoy the
tuesday and even if it is just my
tuesday
it is like that is one of the first
things i'm waiting i'm very curious
every tuesday where they go so
no it's like if this is the way the
episodes are doled out in a weekly basis
they've been stepping up the game and i
can i can live with this
but i got it every so often i'm just
like you know could i blow through the
story
if somebody jumps into this story or
this season like eight weeks later
they're gonna have a lot to wrap their
head around oh yeah yeah that's addict
he waits the last minute i will say did
you brought up perspective
one part that is again i don't agree
with actually but there's some parts
that is funny that i'm like all right
she may have a point here is that like
when you do an expunge
and she's like you know she's talking
about the vex tech or whatever and she's
going into this and
she's like meanwhile we don't invite
them to our homes
like like so she's like you know they're
the enemy we
i can respect their power but we're not
gonna put them in the same tower as i
and i'm like this girl is off the
channel
yeah she's in her bag like it's i always
felt the writing is good
when writing is always good when you at
sometimes some point can
sympathize or empathize with the villain
and even though
she is out of control there are some
bars that she has been putting down
that's kind of funny to me i'm like well
she not got a point no one
they didn't ask this the people in the
city for their permission to bring the
phone
i was like you got a point with certain
things even though she's completely over
the top yeah is this a democracy it's
like
[Music]
not really it's good it's good i'm dying
to see
where i go but say yes say got his
moment to shine you know we got to see
the
you know the the inner side the softer
side
and how he did feel you know remorse for
a lot of the stuff
how he's viewed by the elixir children
like i got
the expunge mission done in four minutes
18 seconds was my fastest but don't
don't beat it too fast or don't beat the
boss too fast i will
say because you break it really yeah you
can nuke him and it just sticks
it'll it'll glitch out the mission
i hit him a couple times with a grenade
launcher and breaching clear
and then if you go curious of the
falling star nuke him with thunder crash
you just sit there and the timer just
takes forever oh no
i broke him yeah so i had it really fast
once i was like damn so i had to go a
little slower and i was like all right
i did about five minutes in a video and
just like took the super out of the
equation for the guide that i did and i
was just like
not too fast but yeah it's like you can
you can i did yeah because you can get
to that boss section like two and a half
minutes when you run so
yeah it's actually it's cool um but i
have enjoyed like being inside the vex
network and stuff like that
from like week one milan everybody else
is talking about quaria blade transform
to wonder if like if quaria is the one
that's like
causing the simulation and then if
that's the case
is it causing lakshmi to do this like is
is lakshmi being
manipulated is it sabathun doing the
manipulation like
how far all of these chains go and this
always just takes me back to
the famous setting up the dominoes that
savithun is doing and i keep
wondering again like this season's like
now we got some civil war strife going
on within the city we got the avengers
possible coming together of fallen and
cabal
and don't know what else is going to be
going on and then season 15
is this gonna be this like eight month
season and i don't know how they're
going to tell the story that's going to
go into potentially the kickoff of the
next trilogy and i'm just going
i don't know where they're going with
this thing and i don't know how all the
pieces are going to fit together but
they are setting up a lot of things
right now crow as you guys have said
osiris you know theoretically loses
ghosts some people have some big
suspicions about osiris being
maybe maybe not so great like there's a
lot of question mark cards and new red
if he was in here probably call that one
up but there's
there's so much they're setting up right
now i'm
the little weekly stories will be the
thing but where being a part of this
journey
that's again i think why evan bringing
it all the way back around is
which queen is having so much built up
to it from taken king on
and now this little stuff that we're
getting into we want that moment
and i just hope they can deliver at some
point
i think that's that's the big one at
this point is like in avengers in game
was better than it ever could have been
because they actually didn't ruin
something that took 23 movie 22 movies
to build
if they do a destiny franchise finish
however it's like which queen lightfall
whatever's after that whatever they have
planned
man i hope it's good i hope so too
i i i am really
interested to see what they meant by
this is only chapter one that's
that's what i'm very curious because
i i feel like i'm gonna be in a
retirement home when this game is done
when this franchise is over the
franchise yeah
movies animations
and we have movies and tv shows
books other games probably a different
ip from bungie in the next few years
like
there is so much that they're doing
but i'm also sitting here like okay
are we gonna kill sabbath dude in the
witch queen please like please
are we ever going to meet the veil like
those are the others are you ever going
to meet the veil are we ever going to
kill
sabathune are we ever going to like what
is callus doing right now
the nine yeah the nines the nine
anything yeah yeah i'd love to know what
continues with like elsie
and clovis because they like beyond
light
set up this like massively cool new
world brought elsie back you've got like
you know the anti-vanguard trio there
and then it's just like
poof and they do that every all like all
the time with these little like
yeah and here's chapter three and you're
like part two of the book that's like
two years from now you're like
damn it like i can you complete one of
these and that's why i was like the
avengers moment like if you set all this
stuff up man i hope they have good
enough writing to
somehow bring it all together it's like
when i was reading the uh the game of
thrones books
like every single time you would read
the books you just like
it just to go off of that you go like
because you'd hit a chapter that would
say john
or like rob or whatever and then and you
know i got nothing against daenerys i
think daenerys is a cool character in
the show
but whenever you turn that page and see
the danny chapter you'd be like
all right i'm in for one all right cool
and then you know you read through it
and then you go to the next one you're
like oh
sick back you know back to back to john
or back
back to uh back to tyrion like okay this
stuff is
or i mean just cersei's chapters were
just really cool too like all those
things but like
you turned the page to be like all right
danny all right cool
the danny disrespect the danny chapters
were not as interesting to me
as like the other things because she was
always like
she's always the character that's like
the the do-gooder type of character and
you're like
i like the do-gooder character like i
think that's really nice but at the same
time i'm ready to hear i'm here for some
drama in this book
i'm ready well that's what i'm here i'm
here to read about tyrion's stuff i'm
here to read about like him preaching
the high council like everything you
know
but that's the thing to even sit back
look back at that show
like her world is so much of like trying
to find
you know her army and doing all these
things she like was just this little
thing every so often you're like
is that like hers was building for about
eight seasons and that book doesn't even
exist yet so her fun stuff
hasn't even happened in the books yet
it's insane so i was like so i can only
imagine when you get to those chapters
it's like
well we're walking around with all the
eunuchs again and my army is
protecting me and we're and it's like i
can i didn't read them but i can
definitely can picture that now that you
say that because yeah you go through
about six seasons
danny's like danny is the outside
building phil
on the other side of westeros like she's
she's still over there
and everybody is still over here and
it's like all right cool now we're gonna
you know yeah it's like not the same
thing with like the disconnects of stuff
with with destiny where it's like
all right now we have the aeris moore
chapter all right now we have
the aramis chapter now we have like
and and you're so excited to hear about
you know this chapter with this
character like oh my god i want to know
is the drifter a good guy is he a bad
guy where is his backstory
i want to have a whole year dedicated to
just this guy's story and then
the next chapter it's like yeah but what
if we just decided to uh
introduce a whole new character seven
years and you're like
man just please give me the payoff of
like one of these stories
i think beyond like i actually
don't i don't think there's anything
left for clovis
else i think anna bray has something
left because there's still that whole
thing with rasputin that we have no idea
like what's going on with rasputin
yeah but i don't think elsie
or clovis really have anything left like
i don't really i can't really think
other than like
elsie helping us i don't think she has
like a story anymore because i feel like
they did
the whole story of like her background
with clovis and and clovis the story of
of his background in the raid like i
feel like the only thing we would
potentially get
is like anna going to clovis and being
like hey rasputin is no longer able to
work here
how can we fix him that would be kind of
the only thing that i could see them
going with
but even then like i don't know i i
don't think that um there's anything
really left with
with the brave family outside of anna
yeah
i could see that no if you if you were
looking at the season right now so far
what would be your uh retrospective be
about
this season yeah so far since i know
it's not done it's early
well i already made a video about vlog
that was over an hour long
that came out earlier this week yep um
vlog video and then
i guess you'll probably have to see how
the story ends to be like that time that
you know
the fallen became our allies and yeah
the civil war started or something
like if there's like a world event type
of deal this season
then i'm in for sure we are due for one
of those yeah
for sure for sure but
i kind of feel like like i had this
weird feeling because of the way expunge
is set up because the way like
they did the promotional material where
there was like a secret code in the
trailers and stuff because of all that
stuff
i i kind of have this hunch that they're
kind of teasing a puzzle like a
community puzzle
that would be cool like then that's an
easy event to cover and like i love
community puzzles
i don't necessarily love staying up for
six days in a row
but no one knows but that was still a
crazy thing like niobe
and then followed that up the next year
with uh with corridors of time like
those are cool events and that's stuff
that gets people excited to watch and be
a part of destiny
so if there's more like that if there's
a new one this season
i mean that'll probably be the easiest
one people wanted me to cover pressage
i'm gonna cover pressage eventually i
was kind of waiting because i
i saw that somebody had ubed into the
room at like the first day
there was like a crown of sorrow helmet
in there so i was like waiting for maybe
like
master pressage might have it you know
i'm gonna wait on prestige and then it
turned out you just
needed to get all of the all the files
or open all the chests in there yeah
and i was like man i should have made
the pressage video way before
um so i'm gonna have to make a presage
video pretty soon i mean i i don't i
don't know i'm not in a rush for
pressage i was gonna say
that one you could like let breathe at
this point be like hey remember this
time we went
on to the alien isolation in destiny
yeah there you go
no for sure like those things i can i
can let breathe but
uh as far as like anything this season
that's like
i have to make a video immediately i
think i already did which is like
vaulted glass like i don't really think
there's another like
big i have to make this as soon as it
comes out
but uh if there was anything it'd
probably be like
i don't even know like maybe expunge
missions being cool and like where they
could go with introducing new mechanics
but that'd be like
years down the road like that's the
thing about my channel is like you know
you got to find things that
people are nostalgic about not things
that people are
really uh kind of like it's fresh in
their mind
about in a way
because you want to like like menagerie
would at this point would be something
that i could make a video about
because menagerie is like people loved
it people want it back
but that's and that's something that
people would be happy to watch
i don't think people would be happy to
watch maybe they would i don't know but
like i don't think as many people would
be happy to watch me make a video about
like
hey the expunged mission this week was
pretty cool like that's just not my type
of content and
there's not a lot for me to talk about
there it's like we we pretty much talked
about it in the
in the one question that we already had
together it was like you know
the exposure mission cool you know laxmi
is a is a little weird
like and uh mythrax is
is trying to explain to saint 14 same 14
made mistakes
he now has to repent those like sins
that he made and you know like all these
different things like you know like
there's
those that's the fun stuff we can talk
about in like the group discussion but i
don't think that's something that i
could make a video on unless it's a
recap at the end of the season
not fair enough make sense
well you got any other uh
questions or anything because i was like
the twab was pretty light honestly yeah
i did want a shout out
um outside of the fashion contest which
is just blowing up my twitter right now
it will not stop because
you know they call a bungee and they're
just like look at all these cool people
i'm like stop my twitter
um so they're doing that but i did want
to say
two things one uh the women at bungie
whole thing is really really cool check
that one out let's look at the
international women's day pin i've seen
people getting those on twitter
they've got a whole well women at bungie
like
inclusion club because honestly in the
world of gaming it's a boys club so the
fact that this is like an inclusion
they're trying to
bungee's like gotta be one of the top
leaders publicly especially that i've
probably ever seen
for anything for inclusion support
openness and everything else
and just really cool to see them
stepping this one up as well so i wanted
to make sure to shout that one out
they've got a full write-up on it um so
go check the blog
and check that one out and the other
piece is going to be gcx which is going
to be going on next week
um shout out creator i'm sure a couple
of you guys are as well
so i'll be roaming around the space
station over the course of
the weekend uh june 17th through june
20th so
i'll be around checking it out advanced
gg shout out they're gonna have a booth
uh but there's also going to be an
exclusive ghost
so you have to actually roam around and
find all seven hidden ghosts just like
the destiny one days
and all the collectibles and there is an
exclusive emblem that you can earn from
doing that
also everything right now uh going
through bungie store
everything is going to st children's hot
st juice hospital
they'll be doing their like donation
block coming up all that crazy stuff
starts with gcx and this is the time
when it's like
how much are they going to collect this
time and it's like how much
last year was like i think it was 6
million or something for saint jude's
over the course of the marathon
oh yeah plus everything that leads up to
it is just bonkers
i don't know if you guys saw like
blessing did like 100k
like kyle blessing if you guys know him
awesome stuff he did like 100k and then
it's like
he was playing i think something with
like reggie it's just
such cool stuff this time of year with
the gcx and all the charity drives and
stuff so
definitely check out gcx check out the
charity drive so you've got some emblems
you can
donate make sure you read the specifics
on the emblems and things like that if
you want the special emblem for
donations
it is in a specific 50 donation not like
30 plus 20.
if it's a 50 donation that's how they're
gonna do the filtering so
if you want to get in for the eris moore
and sign statues there's a certain
number of those seven dollar donations
so
there are a couple of things if you guys
want to get in the mix for all the gcx
supporting it's all going to st
jude's check that stuff out i wanted to
make sure and um
shout that one out for sure um
other than that there are some like
known issues and changes for golden gun
a couple things and
technicalities that i'm not going to get
into right now yep i get my boots of
assembler working right
yeah yeah that's what i need because
that's one of my favorite new exotics
and shout out to ue for putting me on
sleeper
finally it's gonna be coming sleepers
getting buffed to like
16 and a half percent buff i think
that's
gonna be pretty potent i think
everybody's mentioning
that catalyst broke me i was so angry i
finally got it done
only to see this sleeper buff not affect
one of my favorite weapons
and be still relegated to not being the
top
exotic and i'm like ah so i can't wait
till
finally when it when hopefully the next
patch yeah
i think the next patch is going to be
next month i think they said july is the
next year
this month so hopefully best be back
going to sleep at buff man
got it ready yeah well i mean that's all
that i think we've got i know we're kind
of getting close to about that perfect
time for evan as well so i wanted to
wrap this thing up about on time but
before we go wanted to shout you out sir
thank you for joining us it was an
absolute pleasure to have you on had an
absolute blessing
thank you yeah um and
at this point the floor is yours to let
people know if there's anything that you
got teased in the patreon where they can
support you what you got cooking
yeah what you enjoy doing and just the
floor is yours tell him everything it's
it's your time oh well i mean
since you're putting me on it's not
necessarily a shameless plug but i'll
i'll
plug it plug everything um no
shamelessness i
just started uh if anybody has or hasn't
seen the baltic last video it's over an
hour long it's about the like raid race
story the teams that were involved like
it's really cool
and it took a lot of time to put
together i think it took over a month i
was sick
two different times one was an actual
like like i had i didn't have i didn't
have coronavirus i had
um like a bad stomach bug and then right
after
two days after i went and got my vaccine
for my second moderna
vaccine so i got so i got sick for four
days after that
man so i was like double sick writing
this script the script ended up being
like over 30 pages long it was
super super super fun to make though but
like it was just
a crazy project that took forever to
make and like it was it
got slightly delayed because of that
stuff but um
we ended up dropping the 15th wish
video the unsolved mystery of that like
i said that's my favorite video i've
ever made it was the hardest video well
well i i i it was definitely the hardest
video i've ever made
that is for sure um and that was crazy
crazy
um just how much went and went into it
just in every single aspect it's
literally like
a movie um so that one is available on
patreon right now
and i will be releasing it actually this
is the first time i've said this but i
will be releasing it on the 21st of june
to youtube
but if you wanted to watch it early it's
on patreon and then also
you know shameless shameless shameless
um i did
a exclusive merch strap as well with uh
with this wonderful
talented uh artist named nogi son who
made
a beautiful design of inspired by aatrex
so it's
and it's and it's it's actually if you
see in the background
it's on that display right there okay
okay i can grab it real quick
let's see this thing to the front bring
that to the front we'll see see what's
going on over there
see with that fire that heat rock oh
dude that is fantastic that's clean like
dude
yes that's fire in the background it was
that there's a lot she's she's insanely
talented
so like yeah if you guys are listening
to the audio
check us out on video i'll try and time
stamp this thing for kind of the outro
stuff
so if you listen and you want to find
the video be right here tucked in
towards the end
that that thing's amazing that's
fantastic man i'm always so blown away
by like what artists put together
sometimes
and you're just scrolling through did
you i think i tagged you on a cog the
vault of glass one
from uh be serious dude that was
there's a really good i'm just
continuously blown away by artists and
stuff like that all the time it's so
cool that i follow enough of those now
that
um havoc dropping the bits thank you
very much there at the end
um man that's yeah go support this man
putting in like a month's worth of like
deathbed work over there trying to get
this video out for the 15th wish so yeah
go watch it early throws throw some
patreon on his way subscribe to his
twitch channel
find him on twitter find him on
hopefully a twitter thing gets resolved
but that's a
story for another day but yeah on
twitter it's just an underscore yeah
have an f 1997 underscore until
until resolved
[Laughter]
that's all that's that's so that's yeah
that's messed up but yeah we've talked
about that
well thank you sir cog what else you got
coming besides how many hours are you
going to be talking about uh xbox coming
up i mean
your predictions was long mm-hmm is it
prediction
so what xbox for me hits it's going to
be one o'clock for xbox for you right
yeah one so literally the same time we
would normally do iop
so are you going to live do it and then
talk about are you going to wait for it
to go and then do it after
no no we're doing it live we're going to
do a live reaction we're doing it live
we're doing it live we're doing it live
yeah probably like uh
hopefully in that one more than 30
minutes afterwards after the show just a
little recap
talk about it but um yeah man you said
check us out sunday 1 p.m eastern
ireland's podcast youtube
and um yes appreciate the support this
is big for us big week for us a lot of
news and stuff
and go to lawrencegaming.net if you guys
can uh again
tons of articles we got approved for our
media access at e3
so there's been a ton of articles of all
the games coming out your elden ring
and summer games fest stuff as well so
check that stuff out and we would also
do in a series called the lord's minute
where we kind of grab one of the lords
up and we we have
various usually a one subject five to
ten minute kind of topic
and a couple of guys are hardcore
destiny guys on the website so they'll
pull me up they're like
we got to talk about what's going on you
know say to the season so i love to do
those
shout out to the team shout out to tai
shout out to everyone
you know josh and those guys so salute
so like i said check us out
sunday and uh we'll be be doing it big
and and the e3 coverage continues and
then of course
that last word podcast we really
appreciate everyone
you know pulling up coming through the
support having you a fantastic
love thank you story yeah man really
good stuff really good content really
good content
i love the vibe it's almost like the his
the history channel bob
ma'am yeah fun way like that's the
channel
yeah like it's truly truly dope so
salute to you on that
and e man but you gotta i snuck into one
of your
your mass effect stream i was very very
yes yes
he was playing about eight hours in a
mass effect and apparently
did the citadel to start kind of
wandered out i found
who's the blue lady i can't remember her
name right now oh
liara i got her released from prison
freedom yep so i freed her and then i
was like okay what do i do next and i
did the entire asteroid
x-57 i did the whole thing and i learned
that that was just the dlc i was like
okay whoops no there's no wrong way
no i know but i was like that was just
like random to come across but so far
that's kind of one of those like that
sets a really high standard for world
building for me even just like eight
hours the world
like the if you ask them the questions
like i want to know more about this that
and if you actually pay attention to the
world they build in mass effect
it's large and it's cool to see like
destiny is following in suit like the
world they build
here now we're seeing more lore now
we're seeing some um
like all the backgrounds of these
stories and the characters coming
through it's like
story can make a game if done well and
definitely cool to see
destiny stepping up its game and it's
kind of really cool to go back and
experience something like that that
really set a bar that
so many people hold in higher regards so
and one thing i would highly advise
and i'm still mad that no other video
game has copied this
is the codex for the lore have you gone
to the kodak section i've seen
a couple pieces i just haven't dug deep
because i've been just trying to
experience the games over
the thing about them it's it's literally
destiny grimoire in in game
with picture and narrated
so uh if you want to learn about to get
like its voice the guy's like the
guesthouse
and you're like oh okay and it's got the
little picture it's got a good
description
so yeah when you get a chance check out
the codex section
and just check on any of the alien races
or anything and you'll learn a lot and i
just wish more games
don't do that because it's really it's
great for world building
yeah uh but other than that for me uh
shout outs
um kind of got my official thing going
on for advanced gg
oh so 30 off uh if you use code
ebontis30
so if you guys are looking to check that
out they literally just dropped the sour
watermelon flavor today so i cannot wait
to taste that's what that one
here in either like kind of like
watermelon jolly rancher
sour patch well if it's anything like
sour patch watermelon or watermelon
jolly manager i'm in trouble
because yeah that one's going to be
duking it out for a top spot so yeah
that's good through sunday so depending
on when you guys here see this one
otherwise
ivantis is percent off uh but other than
that man
that it's evontus everywhere youtube
twitch twitter all that stuff you guys
know what i do
um evan i know you gotta go so we wanna
wrap this thing up sorry we ran a smidge
long on you but
but thank you very much for coming in
glad to have you this is an absolute
blast like next time we get like a crazy
uh
crazy situation happening we'll have to
see about bringing you back through
because
it was definitely a hard chat and any
souls person might have to see when
elden ring comes back and i'd have to
bring you on for a little uh
double time for sure yeah gotta bring
him back which queen is hot and i'm
gonna say see evan i told you
it was good
i gotta mess with him i gotta mess with
him oh that's pretty good
um but that's pretty much all we got for
right now i'm gonna send you guys over
to amaze here in just a second i know
he's streaming right now so
send the love over to the hype man of
twitch uh but for now we're gonna wrap
this one up thank you guys very much
episode number 153
with evan it is june 11th and for this
episode
it has been the last word